many people in Europe associate
Mitsubishi with either cheap small cars
a robust SUVs we're taking one of its
crossover models out for a spin
the Outlander explains our car man
Sasha's one of the most popular SUVs in
the world and Germany is still just a
niche product but the 2017 edition could
change that in Quinta das Summa and
bassoon Vita keulegan and Europe the
Outlander comes with a choice of two
engines a 2.2 litre diesel and a 2 liter
gasoline unit both are available with
optional all-wheel-drive Sacha is
driving the diesel version with
all-wheel drive his first impression is
that while this vehicle will get you
through thick and thin it won't do it
very quickly it slowed down by its
weight and the top equipment line with
all-wheel drive some 117 kilos more than
the entry version with front-wheel drive
the diesel Edition needs 11.6 seconds to
make the dash to 100 kilometers an hour
top speed with a six-speed automatic
transmission is just less than an
overwhelming 190 kilometers per hour
our kiss car is fitted with adaptive
all-wheel drive an eco mode the one axle
is deployed almost exclusively this does
theoretically allow you to meet the
manufacturers official fuel economy
rating of 5.8 liters per 100 kilometers
all-wheel drive only kicks in when the
wheels start to slip the most
outstanding change for Sasha the one
that no longer stands out is that the
rear antenna has been replaced by this
little shark fin the car is now a bit
more streamlined one change Sasha would
like to make and it's the same with most
car makers is the unbearably slow
opening trunk lid and winter you really
wish would open a bit faster but once
you've folded down all five rear seats
you have a flat cargo platform and a
total volume of 1613 litres and that's
nothing to sneeze at the third row of
seats is only available with the diesel
Edition gasoline engine buyers will have
to make do with five seats Sasha
appreciates the legroom in the back but
not the Headroom even with his short
hair he's touching the roof lining and
he's worried about getting it dirty
because he has a bit of gel in his hair
Sasha would have preferred this little
bulge here further forward so that he
would sit more comfortably but Simba
criminals it'll come that bulge in the
restricted Headroom are due to the glass
sunroof the cabin is nice and spacious
and uncluttered
[Music]
there are new piano black accents
although your fingerprints show up
everywhere
the cup holder is now hidden away under
a special cover
[Music]
[Applause]
but the most important new feature in
the Outlander has to be the safety
package available for an extra one
thousand four hundred euros it includes
a blind spot alert that also warns the
driver of rear cross-traffic when
leaving a parking space it's especially
useful in the city not least because of
all those cyclists racing around
insulated windows help to keep out noise
diesel engine does get a bit loud so
Sasha that's primarily due to the
automatic transmission which is pretty
harmonious but sometimes isn't sure what
to do so the engine revs higher than
necessary it's not finished so then at
the same time it costs 2,000 euros extra
and comes without an automatic
start/stop something that Sasha can't
quite comprehend
oh man all the Mitsubishi Outlander is a
solid enough vehicle having
all-wheel-drive available is a big
benefit in the winter or in the
mountains plus you have a lot of space
for the whole family and car goes it's
real strength is its price advantage
over German car makers even if the
workmanship loses a couple of points
here and there but that's it